c'est parti
j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone qui
[Musique]
fait mal bon on y va la boîte oui tout
de suite c'est Gisèle que la voiture
celle qui nous amène moi je vais prendre
un café tu viens
gentil tu nous amènes de café tu es bien
mignon aujourd'hui tu es bien habillé il
est con ce serveur je peux pas le voir
je peux pas le voir non
alors Tony tu es gentil tu me mets les
profiteras à la chantilly merci Tony tu
es bien gentil il est con ce serveur je
peux pas je peux pas le faire alors avec
Jacky qu'est-ce qui s'est passé je te
raconte pas oh j'aurais bien aimé que tu
racontes attends je te raconne
tu la connais la Golf GTI à Jacky oui
allez moi bien que la Turbo de René
quand même mais la Turbo de René c'est
une de chevaux turbo non mais c'est le
turbo quand même pas grave il s'est
passé je te raconte pas j'aurais bien
aimé que tu racontes bah attends je te
raconte alors vas-y raconte alors Jacky
il voulait mettre son prénom et le mien
sur le pare-brise Jacky et Véronique
c'est gentil hein mais il y avait pas
assez de place il a mis Jacquie et nique
c'est une guerre les boules que j'ai que
sur je vais te dire les garçons tous les
mêmes et oui tu sors avec elle tu les
connais tous moi je les connais tous
j'arrive pas à me sortir ouais c'est mon
problème remarque que tu sais Jacky au
début oui je le connaissais à peine tu
sais pas ce qui me dit il me dit on va
chez toi on va chez moi je suis pas
comme ça moi hein et alors on est allé à
l'hôtel
non je me suis lavé les cheveux ah oui
tout va bien aussi Tony merci tu es bien
mais il est con ce serveur il a mis les
amendes dans la chantilly j'avais dit
pas les amandes dans la chatte mais pas
les amas de l'origine bon allez je vais
t'aider voilà force
du sac c'est le fourbi toujours c'est le
Bibard
l'horoscope
toujours c'est quoi ton signe vierge et
ben c'est mieux que crapaud quand même
alors vierge amour ce n'est pas votre
jour vous ne rencontrerez pas l'amour de
votre vie et B et B ça tombe bien j'ai
mes règles
elle est bonne la secrétaire la sucette
Jean-Luc c'est joli que je veux pas le
voir
il est bête c'est pas ce qu'il a dit
l'autre jour Macumba club 84
c'est parce qu'il a dit il a dit qu'il
avait dragué c'est pas vrai n'importe
quoi les mêmes dit que tu avais
embrasser mais c'est pas vrai si même
que tu avais couché avec lui oh c'est
pas vrai
ah ça c'est vrai ça
puisque là là-bas elle n'arrête pas de
nous regarder j'avais comment les
maquiller j'ai vu le polype dure elle se
maquillée chérie poulet
c'est aussi
et les deux boudins ah non ça c'est nous
dans les glaces
[Musique]
dis le rouge moi c'est ça quoi tiens tu
as changé de coiffure là je me suis lavé
les cheveux voilà allez on y va à la
boîte oh non c'est galère je vous
raconte fort mais pourquoi tu as pas la
voiture si mais j'ai loupé le permis
c'est pas vrai oh je suis tombé sur un
mec il me l'a pas donné tout ça parce
que j'ai calé sur une voie ferrée
[Musique]
du ah tu as mis du gel ça va bien le gel
Gisèle non c'est pas ça mais ils sont
grave sensibles
j'ai proposé à Stéphanie de venir oh
elle a pas le moral mais elle a une
voiture
non Stéphanie on y va on est vachement à
la bourre
ça va j'ai compris j'ai toujours pareil
à chaque fois écoute Stéphanie tu
devrais plus y penser je veux dire tu
veux prendre une consommation oui
qu'est-ce que tu veux prendre
quelque chose on va chercher les
consommations ça te fera du bien moi je
prendrai un Monaco
pour Stéphanie de Monaco
alors qu'est-ce qui
se passe son mec je te raconte pas
j'aurais bien aimé que tu racontes
par son mec Jean-Louis
Le Grand là qui ressemble à Yannick Noah
Jean-Jacques Goldman
et moi je craque pour Jean-Jacques
Goldman oh oui Jean-Jacques Goldman
c'est où il veut quand il veut
genre ça serait plutôt Anthony de l'eau
qui c'est un tenue de LoL le fils à
Belmondo
Jean-Jacques Goldman que les mecs à la
mode soyez original les filles que tu
préfères toi Christophe Lambert je
craque ah mince en parlant de lui j'ai
inversé les lentilles
merci Stéphanie
tu t'es lavé les cheveux non j'ai changé
de coiffure
après on va en boîte
vraiment je comprends pas je peux pas
vivre sa vie non Jean-Louis
[Musique]
un peu il faut le comprendre si tu as
laissé tomber
la tête
et puis il est con ce serveur il a pas
débouché la Colombo mais qu'est-ce qu'il
a il est complètement largué
c'est pas grave Gisèle elle va te donner
sa bague tu veux ma bague elle est jolie
elle est en or non elle est plaqué
Stéphanie prends ta pilule on va en
boîte non je n'ai pas besoin si il y a
pas de Jean-Louis il est moche il y a
même Jacques Pradel et Dominique
verdayan
et je vais en prendre deux alors
c'est toi je veux dire mais c'est pas
possible ma voiture elle est en panne
[Musique]